all praise is due to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
beyond gracious
beyond merciful
the one whom guides and for who he
guides
they cannot be misguided
and for who he misguides they cannot be
guided to the truth
i testify that allah is the only
only not even thing
nothing
that can be worshipped
because no word can encompass what he is
and i testify by allah
that prophet muhammad
is the final prophet
the seal of the prophets
the most perfect man to have ever walked
this earth
and the greatest example for all of us a
mercy sent to mankind
i ask of you all to make a dua for me
that i
may be able to communicate with you in
the most coherent manner possible
um this is actually my first major
lecture
um
and i am actually quite nervous
so if you could please make a dough for
me i really appreciate that and then
i'll let me accept my deeds today that
it may be weighed
on
the good scale on the day of judgment
and then it may be expiation from my
sins
prior to getting into this uh
interesting lecture i'd like to tell you
a little bit about myself and why i'm
standing up here today
i
have been studying this very subject
here for the past seven years of my
academic career
i did my bachelor's in western
philosophy i did my master's in
islamic philosophy
and
well
i decided to change career paths after
that so now i'm doing my phd in sharia
because my mother inquired how i was
going to get a job
with philosophy degree
and i used to tell her that i can think
long deep thoughts about unemployment
but
so i decided to change my my my degree
to sharia
and um she told me oh that's so good you
know now you can do law and other such
things and my phd thesis is on isis
so um she wasn't quite happy about that
because you know now it seems as though
i might be in danger in the future
uh but at least my life has gotten a
little bit more exciting
um
let's see i am also uh from the united
states uh however my family is
originally from spain hence my title
alan delusio so in case any of you have
any
confusion about that so i think that's
enough about me
i don't want to make this whole lecture
about myself so
let's actually get right into it
if you could please
lovely
okay
okay so why are we here why are we
discussing atheism today uh many of you
have uh signed up for this course to
learn about atheism to understand
atheism
um at least i hope so unless you're here
just because you're bored i mean you
know that's another thing you can do
but why are we here to discuss atheism
well atheism is actually a rising
problem globally
a recent report
and gallup poll international 2012 and
this is the most recent that they
currently have actually we haven't
gotten anything
more recent than that
um showed that there was a rise of
atheism globally at three percent and a
steady decline of religiosity at nine
percent
okay um some of the countries mentioned
show the following numbers of convinced
atheism within their populations if you
could please click the uh keep going
saudi arabia palestine
pakistan and malaysia
so i picked some muslim countries here
to to
you know pique your interest a little
bit
uh so let's see what about saudi arabia
five percent convinced atheist please uh
wait for me to
uh who thinks uh what about palestine
who here can answer me
how many atheists convince atheists are
in palestine i'm not talking about
israel i'm talking about gaza and the
west bank
17 atheist mashallah
okay
wow
anybody any else
10 a little bit high
we'll say about 4
okay
how about pakistan mostly majority
probably what 99 percent
you try that one how many
you guys are really pessimistic
it's like you're shooting really high
can you go
okay
how about malaysia
one percent alhamdulillah right
zero
zero percent convinced atheist in
malaysia apparently we're going to get
to that in a second but before we do
before i discuss these numbers and what
they actually mean
okay for the given populations that i've
just listed i want to mention how many
registered as irreligious
can you please click
19 for saudi arabia claim
that they are not religious muslims
okay
29 of palestine
that's almost a third of the whole
population
claims that they are not religious at
all meaning they just believe in god
okay they don't practice
eight percent in pakistan and 13
malaysia
13. all right now if we combine these
numbers obviously it's a little bit
higher now it's more significant
okay and there's actually a correlation
between these numbers you may think that
being non-religious
means that it has no connection to
atheism but actually that there's that's
quite the opposite is true if we can go
on please
and one of the reasons i i speculate
about the zero percent in malaysia is
because of forums like this
uh i'm a member of this group don't
don't question my akita now okay because
i'm not an atheist all right i come here
to practice
and what i mean by practice is i like to
use people's punching bags for my
arguments
and i like to test my arguments out on
atheists so i go online sometimes and
you know poke at them so
this forum is called what on atheist i
hope i pronounced that right i'm not
malaysian i'm sorry um and it has
3537 members most of them claim to be
murtadin
okay so you have
over 3 000
if you count give a few maybe the
theists in there that are arguing okay
over 3 000 apostates
on this forum alone
all right so that zero percent seems a
little bit uh
doesn't make much sense does it and this
is actually my facebook page so i'm
seeing some of the brothers here
probably on their phones trying to add
me
so okay you can save it for later
uh sisters please don't do that
uh not saying that you are but uh
my my future wife might kill me so
please don't do that
okay so if we can yeah future i'm still
keeping it that way
so
next okay
please
one more
all right so let's go to uh
some more information that i found
rather shocking rather startling if you
click again
atheism by religious affiliation
actually these same
researchers
they did surveys on people who claim to
be of certain religious groups
interesting right on a global scale so
let's look at those religious groups if
we could among the major religious
affiliations surveyed on a global scale
the following percentages have either
declared themselves convinced atheists
that'll be the first number you see
non-religious
and or undecided meaning they don't know
if they're atheist or not yet
okay
can we go to the uh next christian
jewish
hindu and muslim
okay so let's see about christians
declared atheist convinced one percent
globally
not bad
jewish two percent not surprised
hindu
three percent
muslim
of the global population of muslims
is considered to be convinced atheists
people who say that they're muslim but
yet they're actually
atheists
okay these are people who have yet to
apostate maybe or maybe they have
apostate and they just
they still declare the title so this is
non-religiosity among the christians is
jewish 54 once again not surprised
hindu 12 muslim 20
non-religious globally so now you have
23 percent
basically
on the edge of their faith or completely
outside
okay this is only in 2012 the numbers
have risen since then we don't know the
exact
percentages
but i think saudi arabia now as i
said was five percent last time but i
think it rose to six or seven
in the past few years
that's almost 10 of the population that
has now convinced atheists out of a
majority muslim population in the most
conservative
parts
of the middle east and the muslim world
in general and the undecideds four
percent for christian jewish six percent
hindu three and muslim three so in terms
of
the potential atheist you have 23 in the
muslim world
so almost a third of the global muslim
population
is either not religious
or they're becoming atheist
does that sound uh
a little shocking
how many muslims are in the world
a little higher than that
it's about 1.8 something though
so what's 20 percent of that population
can you imagine
you can do the math by yourself i'm not
going to do it in my head because i'll
have a headache but
um
but imagine that's a very significant
number
okay
please continue
all right let's see
islamic scholars are only now starting
to address this i just read this report
recently the world bulletin
click again please
egyptians uh egypt's muslim christian
authorities unite against atheism
and i'm going to read you this little
story here
christian churches in egypt say they're
joining forces with egypt's al-azhar
okay so the christians are the ones who
approach the muslims
all right
the church and al-assad are drafting a
constructive mechanism to address
atheism
this statement came following a two-day
conference organized jointly between
azer and the church aimed at forging a
scholarly response to atheism
which they said has been spreading
increasingly in egypt over the past
three years
okay so they're actually quite alarmed
by this phenomenon they think there's
something very problematic about this
especially among the youth
all right now you're probably wondering
that if the scholars are finally
deciding to construct a response to
atheists why am i standing here
because i'm not a scholar
right
well uh before we go to the next slide
i'd like to explain that
um
the scholarly tradition the ulema
while they are still advanced in arabic
and in terms of the traditional studies
okay
there has been a sharp decline
in terms of how they address
outside religions to be honest with you
they are still utilizing arguments
from several centuries ago
the problem is
that atheists have changed their beliefs
in the past hundred years
and many people don't know that unless
of course you study at the philosophy
department
which uh is unfortunate because it
should be common knowledge
so the arguments that
a lot of the muslims
and the scholars are using are actually
not effective
for this new brand of atheism and we're
going to discuss what that type of
atheism is the contemporary form of
atheism as it is today
please continue
so what does this have to do with me
you're probably wondering to yourself
if you're alarmed at all by these
percentages if you're alarmed at all by
the fact that muslims have
begun to stray away from their religion
if you're alarmed at all that atheism is
actually the fastest growing ideology on
the planet it's not islam by the way
people think it's islam that's not true
atheism is growing at a twenty percent
faster rate
okay
so what does that have to do with me
well first off how about we address the
quran because whenever we want to ask a
question about our lives
we should address the quran and the
sunnah correct okay so what does the
quran say
who could say
who could say anything better than
someone who summons to allah and acts
rightly and says i am one of the muslims
so this is a
this is basically the quran
is basically saying that anyone who does
dawah okay they're the successful ones
this is somebody who is at a very high
rank
okay
continue please
quran also says let there be a community
among you who call to the good and enjoy
the right and forbid the wrong they are
the ones who have success they are the
ones who have success
so right now the quran is telling you
that to do dawah in general in general
is to receive reward okay to or to
correct the wrong is to receive a reward
okay
we have uh the hadith literature
also baxis
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said to ali but allah if a
single person is guided by allah through
you it will be better for you than a
whole lot of red camels now red camels
were also a very valued
asset back then okay so what it means is
if you wanted to translate it into
contemporary terminology a lot of red
ferraris
or a lot of you know diamonds or tons of
gold
anything that you would consider to be
most valuable to you so bringing one
person to islam is more valuable for you
in
the afterlife than
than any sort of material gain
and legrand also provides
sort of the the example that should be
uh the example for you and uh to perform
this deed so you have an excellent model
in the messenger of
allah for all who put their hope in
allah on the last day and remember allah
much continue please
say and this is uh allah speaking to
muhammad sallallahu alaihisam
say this is my way i call to allah with
inner sight
okay
i and
all who follow me glory be to allah i am
not one of the idolaters not one of the
disbelievers
okay
continue
in the sunnah the prophet saw his son
said he was asked something he knows and
conceals it will have a bridle of fire
put on on him on the day of resurrection
so actually the information i'm giving
you today
you should probably spread that around
because it would be very bad not to
um please continue there's actually a
weaker hadith
and we use weak hadith of course to
support we don't always use them for
direct evidence but when they're in you
know they supplement so this one is
actually even more interesting the
messenger of
allah said whoever conceals knowledge
which allah has made beneficial for
mankind's affairs of religion so it's
very specific there if you notice okay
allah will bridle him with the reigns of
fire in the day of resurrection please
continue
the quran continues so do not obey the
disbelievers but use this quran
to battle against them with all your
might
jihad
with the sword of the quran
the hadith states that i heard the
messenger of allah it was saying he who
amongst you see something abominal
should modify with the help of his hand
many people know this hadith already
if he is not strong enough to do so then
with his tongue and if he is still not
strong enough to do so then at least to
a poor in one's heart and that's the
weakest of iman
the weaker
variation of the sort of striving jihad
with your hands your tongues and your
wealth okay
continue and this is what i really want
to discuss actually commenting on the
ayah that we just revealed earlier
okay said jihad with decisive proof and
the tongue takes precedence
over jihad with the sword
and the spear takes precedence meaning
that it's first
beyond all things
today we talk a lot about fighting the
kuffar
but in fact the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam as an example to us said
that the precedence is with your
your tongue first with arguments
argumentation
everyone has a succession of angels in
front of him and behind him guarding by
allah's command allah never changes a
person's state until they change what is
in themselves when allah desires evil
for a people there is no averting it
they have no protector apart from him
now before you go on uh i would like to
explain why i
brought this uh
brought this ayah up
and a lot of people often
misconstrue
and i'm saying this very deliberately
misconstrued this ayah
to mean as a personal endeavor
change myself
if i change myself
then my condition will change however
this is not the case
it can be read in that way however
the traditional opinion
is that it's a collective duty
it's not talking about you personally
okay it's not talking about how you
change yourself
and then your condition will change it's
talking about the community in general
and we have evidence for this from imam
korthabi
and scholar okay
he is probably one of my ancestors i
don't know
so uh
he's commenting on this i hear allah
informs us in this verse that he will
not change a people until change occurs
in them whether from themselves or those
in charge of them or those put over them
for reason however the verse does not
mean that punishment will be sent by
allah for someone who commits a sin
rather punishment and affliction may be
sent down due to the sins of others
based on what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi was saddam replied to when asked
by his companions are we going to be
destroyed even when we have righteous
people among us
where he said yes when filth and
corruption becomes prevalent
and allah knows best
this is a community injunction
when it means that you must change the
condition of yourself before the before
allah does so he's talking about not
just yourself he's talking about also
your community
for instance is not just a personal
matter
faster is only tassel
if you extend it out to your neighbors
imam malik for instance stated that
there is no sharia without tassel wolf
and there's no tussle wolf without what
sharia
the two are interconnected it's
impossible to separate them
so jihad
okay is a collective duty it's an
obligation upon all of us whether by the
tongue whether by the sword or whether
by our wealth
and
it is
incumbent upon us especially when it's
within our own community so this has a
lot to do with us in the sense that we
have a rise
of anti-intellectualism we have a rise
of atheism we have a rise of people who
are becoming apostates in our faith so
it is an obligation upon all of us to do
intellectual jihad
not just for the sake of our own souls
but for the sake of our community around
us
this is not an option
this is absolutely not an option
at all
if we consider that if somebody invades
our territory
our land
our homes kicks down our door
and tries to kill our family
we consider an obligation to fight back
correct
in the same way
our faith
our prophet saws honor
is more important to us than our lives
so our obligation to defend our religion
is much higher than our own lives
okay that's why it said that jihad with
the tongue meaning the intellect takes
precedence
precedence over that of the sword
okay
so what's there to learn
oh there's gonna be a lot actually
okay
well what is atheism and the types of
atheism that's gonna be one
continue
the sword is a small uh
you know table of contents the five most
common atheist beliefs
i'm going to give you all the five most
common ones continue
arguments used by atheists
why is atheism becoming more popular
responding to atheist beliefs and
arguments
common objections to islam by atheists
and disbelievers in general
atheist psychology and how to debate
and introduction to logical fallacies
and uh don't don't go to the next page
yet
basically we're going to cover
um all the way to this point right here
responding to atheist beliefs and
arguments in this day
okay the next day we will go on to
common objections atheist psychology
introduction to logical fallacies
tomorrow i'm basically going to teach
you how to argue
and you're probably asking me well
how can i do that what credentials well
part of my education in philosophy was
that
they teach you how to argue so
i actually had probably i don't know
five or six classes on just logical
fallacies alone
um and a logical fallacy is essentially
just an argument that is invalid or a
statement that's invalid so things that
you commonly that you actually should
not say in an argument i'm going to
teach you how to avoid those things and
how to point them out so that when you
actually get into discussion with
somebody
and
you know you can see whether what
they're saying
is valid
and whether it's worth addressing and
you can point out say look you know i
think you're saying something wrong here
so then you don't have to get diverted
from what you're from your message okay
because actually a lot of people crumble
that up and throw it away so a lot of
people
um usually get diverted by rhetoric a
lot of people they know how to talk in
this day and age but if you actually
examine the way that people talk you'll
notice that there's no substance to most
of it
so what is atheism and this is probably
going to be the most important thing
that we need to learn right now because
definitions matter before we talk about
a subject we need to know what it is
obviously so
atheism in the dictionary today the
oxford dictionary says uh states that
the disbelief or lack of belief in god
are gods now before we go on
i like to ask is anybody here understand
this definition
does anybody know the distinctions
or what this definition is trying to say
because
prior to about 10 years
in the recent decade
this definition used to be only one of
these two there was no or
it was only one
it was
the disbelief
in god meaning the belief that god does
not exist
so now it's recently changed by
including lack of belief in god or god's
and that's actually a very important
distinction which we're going to get
into because um
that actually defines the majority of
atheists in the world today most
atheists will not say they believe god
does not exist
most i'm talking about 99
wouldn't say that they
simply lack a belief in god
uh we will get to the
question answers we'll get to the to
that uh as well um
but you are correct to some degree
except that atheists have actually
combined
the concept of gnosticism with atheism
now
and i'll show you how they did that
so the origins of the late 16th century
from the french ethics me from the greek
atheos
from the negative a which means without
and theos which is god
okay continue please
historical fun fact
one more
the word atheism was commonly used by
certain religious communities against
other religious communities
the first time that it was actually used
in this way was with the christians
when the christians first came about in
the roman empire the romans called them
atheists because they did not believe in
the pagan gods
they said you don't believe in our gods
you're atheist
and the christians responded said no
you're an atheist because you don't
believe in the true god. so they were
calling each other atheists
during the crusades the muslims and the
christians were calling each other
atheists
believe it or not that's very strange
right because they did not believe
ancient they both said we both basically
we said you don't believe
in allah who is the true god so you're
atheist you don't believe in god and the
christians responded that you don't
believe in
jesus
as a god so therefore you're an atheist
so it was actually it was a much more
specific meaning okay and nowadays this
more broadly means just in general
somebody who doesn't believe in any gods
and so the concept of god itself has
become equalized in the term atheist
okay so what types of atheism are there
okay one more there's practical atheism
which is about behavior
and stop please
and
practical atheism is simply about how
you act
as a person okay your your attitude
towards the existence of god so we have
something under practical atheism called
apathyism
does anybody know the word apathetic
apathetic means you don't you have no
concern for it you don't care
so when i'm apathetic like say about
politics i'm apathetic about politics i
just don't care about politics i do care
about politics i'm just an example but
um so apathyism
is doesn't care if god exists at all so
it's not like
you ask him does god exist he's just
like i it doesn't really matter to me
you know i'm gonna live my life like
this anyway so
you know
um
then there's non-religious
one more
doesn't care about what god desires now
there's actually a distinction between
these
one just doesn't care if god exists the
other one acknowledges god exists but
doesn't care
that he has commands or that he has a
will
he just doesn't
you know he could be a deist
a deist is somebody who believes in god
but a god that doesn't interfere with
the world
but generally a non-religious person is
somebody who who acknowledges there's a
god but acts like an atheist
so somebody who may be for instance a
muslim
but drinks fornicates
does everything an atheist would do and
acts like it's not a big deal
so you know sisters in islam
um
i apologize okay
uh i had to throw that in there
um so then we have theoretical atheism
which is about ideas
and this is the one that we're really
going to be discussing the most here
uh one more please
so there are two types of atheism in the
theoretical level there's strong or
positive atheism which is
the belief that god does not exist
the belief that god does not exist so
they have a firm belief
that god does not exist
okay
then there's weak or negative atheism
that's the one that lacks a belief in
god
they say i don't know
okay they say i don't have enough
evidence
i don't have enough reason to believe
that there's a god i simply lack the
belief that's it
so don't blame me for anything that's
you know so it's sort of it's almost
like a defense mechanism and that they
actually use it that way as well we'll
get into that more later
so these are the this is actually very
general
um
categorization because there's actually
quite a few more atheists but the
popular ones that you're going to be
approached by or that you're going to
approach in your life are going to be
from this area right here the weak
atheist section
and they typically have very common
beliefs whereas the strong atheist i've
dealt with them in philosophy circles
usually professors of philosophy and
things like this they usually have very
strange ideas that you're typically not
going to encounter and i'll give you one
example
i had one professor in college in my
bachelor's when i was doing my
bachelor's and we would have interesting
discussions
and it
and i wasn't concerned so much that he
was an atheist more
i was more concerned about the fact that
he believed something else which i i was
constantly trying to convince him
otherwise
because i just felt it was very absurd
so
his belief was that he didn't know if
the real of the world was real
um
well when you talk to somebody like that
you really can't get any further uh
because if they don't believe the world
is real then
huh
[Music]
uh no actually he was uh he was a
anglo-american former christian
um but he believed the world wasn't real
and i don't mean that he had like a
platonous idea like he thought there was
illusions or anything no he believed he
honestly did not know
whether he
was living in the real world
um so he kind of liked the movie the
matrix a lot so he was always trying to
debate whether what was actually going
on was actually going on
so he was preoccupied with himself quite
a bit and so his atheism was at least my
concerns
and of course by doing that he also
negated his own existence he didn't know
if he actually existed
and you may think that's absurd but
there's actually philosophers that are
like that
and in the philosophy department we have
a strange phenomenon
and this may discourage you from
studying philosophy we have a strange
phenomenon where we call uh nietzsche
burnout
nietzsche burnout you know nietzsche
he's a german existentialist philosopher
he was responsible for the nihilist
movement which means that there was no
values in life basically our values were
determined subjectively by human beings
so basically our values what we consider
to be moral or good or bad is determined
solely by humans
okay based on what we just simply desire
what we consider to be the normal good
whatever
it's all subjective in that sense
well
when somebody becomes a nihilist and
they start to lose their ground in
reality meaning they've jumped into
philosophy so much that they sort of
drown themselves in these skepticism
they end up committing suicide
and i've known a few colleagues
and a few students in my philosophy
department who have unfortunately
succumbed to that because they
questioned themselves too much to the
point where they killed themselves
so um
something else i'd like to mention was
that
theoretical atheism has a direct
causation on the practical atheism okay
so any beliefs that you hear from the
theoretical side
will automatically influence the
behavior of the society that they're in
and we'll get to that more i mean as
well so what are the common beliefs of
atheists
well
before we get into that let's have some
story time
okay
so i brought up a book
that uh you guys are familiar with story
time
you've had story time before
i remember story time i love story time
i miss it a lot you know i'm 30 now
and it's like you know i wish i could go
back to that time so i've decided to uh
to bring you all back
to this time
so i brought a book here
and um i thought i'd tell you a story
it's a fairy tale
about atheism
okay and this is what atheists tell
themselves but it's more of like a
childish fashion so maybe you'll get a
kick out of it i don't know so i'm gonna
sit here
like the good teacher that i am and you
can all just listen okay
all right
that's
good all right once upon a time
i'm serious
paper there once upon a time there was a
terrible monster that lived in the sky
did anybody know this is referring to
yet okay we'll keep going
no one had ever seen it because it lived
a long way away
and because it was invisible
but everyone knew it was there because a
long time ago it had shown itself to
some very clever men
these very clever men explained how the
monster had one head three bodies and a
thousand eyes
which
with which it could see into people's
souls
they told terrible tales of what the
monster would do if they got angry but
also of how kind it was that people
would only worship it without thought or
question
they explained how the monster had given
them a powerful magic which if used
rightly would protect the world from
evil
sometimes the monster would get angry
and when it did the clever man would
offer its sacrifices
dragging people into market squares
where they would burn them alive just to
show the monster how much they loved it
the people listened to the very clever
men and believed them but they still
yearn to be free of the monster
and then one day a few brave men who had
only ever pretended to believe in the
monster
unearthed the chest of strange metal
the chest had been hidden by an earlier
wiser freer people who had lived in the
land before the monster came and had
known a better way of life
ever so slowly the men began to work the
medal which they called
reason
using it to forge a new weapon which
they called science
and they used science to attack the
monster
and the very clever men
they had to be very careful though at
first because if anyone was caught using
science they would be dragged into
market squares where they were burned
alive and indeed this was how many men
lost their lives
but these were brave men not to be
fooled by fables or
threats
their ban multiplied and their weapons
grew in number and power until one day a
brilliant reclusive rebel invented a
super weapon which he called
evolution
which could punch clean to the monster's
armored scales
after that the attacks increased in
frequency and ferocity until one day the
rebels were able to show the people what
they had long known themselves
the monster had never actually existed
it was just a tale told by the very
clever men to keep themselves in riches
in power
slowly the truth spread and although
some very clever men still cling to
riches and power and some very stupid
ones still believe them gradually
wonderfully the world is being set free
the
end
was that a good story
lovely story
okay
well as juvenile as it may seem this is
actually what many atheists believe
so i'm going to put my story chair back
okay so we're gonna get into the actual
academic discussion of those atheist
beliefs
okay and uh i gave you that story
because not just to entertain you but i
actually wanted you to to understand
what they believe and and once you see
what these beliefs are in their academic
fashion you'll start to translate it
into that myth
so the first common belief of the
contemporary atheist is something called
anti-theism okay it's called
anti-theism
theism is the belief in god anti is what
against
okay the belief that theism and religion
in general need to be opposed and
eradicated because they are
intellectually unjustifiable and harmful
to mankind
next please
one such individual by the name of sam
harris from the united states
the author of the end of faith
he's the first new atheist author he
said this if i could wave a magic wand
and get rid of either rape
or religion
i would not hesitate to get rid of
religion
i think more people are dying as a
result of our religious myths than as a
result of any other ideology so this man
says that he would rather get rid of
religion than rape
[Music]
that's
i don't know if that's shocking to you
that i think that's quite disgusting
and i'm sorry to be so direct
um
another uh
famous author by name of christopher
hitchens late christopher christians who
recently passed away a few years ago
i'm not even an atheist so much as i'm
an anti-theist i'd only maintain that
all religions are versions of the same
untruth but i hope that the influence of
churches and the effect of religious
belief is positively harmful
so this is their first major belief
excellent
the next one is evidentialism
this is a philosophical term
evidentialism i'll explain it to you
more the belief that any or all
positions require evidence to be
accepted
in other words a person is justified in
believing not believing or withholding
belief based on whether or not they have
sufficient evidence at the given time a
proposition is made
once this is used in opposition to the
concept often this is used in opposition
to concept of faith or belief without
evidence okay
so the new atheist such as this man
richard dawkins giving a speech in 1992
he said faith is the great cop-out the
great excuse to evade the need to think
and evaluate evidence faith is belief in
spite of even perhaps because of the
lack of evidence
so they base the atheist claim that they
based all of their beliefs
on evidence and they believe and they
base their rejection
of beliefs based on evidence or lack
thereof excuse me
number three scientism
we will get into this term more actually
in the near future
this is actually a word many atheists
will deny this term however it's been
around since the 1800s
maybe even earlier than that
the belief that the methods of natural
science or the categories and things
recognized in natural science form the
only proper elements in any
philosophical or other inquiry in other
words science is the only way to know
anything
the new atheist or the majority of
atheists in the world today actually
believe this
and victor stenger who just recently
died as well uh
he uh wrote in the new atheism defending
richard dawkins sam harris christopher
hitchens and all the other atheist uh
leaders who have written a lot of
literature on the subject could you go
back
sorry
he said
and they recommended this book so they
firmly believe him in this respect the
new atheists firmly insist that the
personal abrahamic or islamic perception
of god is a scientific hypothesis
that can be tested by the standard
methods of science so they honestly
believe
that the concept of god can be tested
using scientific inquiry
okay
next
number four humanism
whatever
okay humanism
the belief that human beings should be
the center of mankind's concerns that we
are the only source of ethics
legislation and values in this world and
that god or gods are unnecessary in
determining our destiny the ancient
greek philosopher epicurus uh would set
the stage for this line of thinking
oh actually that's an error
i want to point out i make errors
sometimes it's not epicurus his name is
euthyphro
okay so i will edit that later for your
convenience i apologize
he said if god is all-powerful then why
can he not stop evil and if he is all
good then why does he refuse
that's a question that we will be
getting into actually later as well it's
called the
the argument
for evil or theodicy issue that brother
reihan had mentioned earlier and ac
grayling who wrote the god argument in
2014 said the human good is for human
responsibility to discern and enact
without reliance upon or invocation of
any
of any of the major religions which
claim a transcendental authority and
posthumous rewards are punishments
so he is basically claiming that human
beings are the only
rulers of their fate and destiny
okay and that we do not need a god to
determine that next
number five
progressionism
this is another philosophical term this
is one that many atheists actually don't
even know they have
um but i've encountered many of these uh
many arguments from the position
and in the belief that humanity is
gradually advancing in science
technology ethics and legislation due to
the absence of religion this belief
became popularized around the time of
the enlightenment okay
uh and christopher hitchens once again
stated one must stated plainly religion
comes from the period of human
prehistory where nobody had the smallest
idea what was going on
okay so basically he's saying that
religion came purely from ignorance in
the past when people didn't have science
it comes from the balling
wow you come faster to me so
it comes from the balling and fearful
infancy of our species and it is a
babyish attempt to meet our inescapable
demand for knowledge all attempts to
reconcile faith with science and reason
are consigned to failure and ridicule
for precisely these reasons
okay next
so
now that we understand the primary
atheist beliefs let's get into their
main arguments
how much time do we have
still good
almost okay 30 minutes left
so the first argument uh by the way i've
cataloged these myself
um this is not from a book
this is from my own personal experience
and study over the years
i've debated with many atheists um
i have discussed with many atheists
philosophers etc so these are my own
um categorizations okay this is what i
have found to be the majority of
arguments throughout the years the
argument for antithesis
so you see p1 here this means premise
one
okay so when you see
in philosophy we like to write our
arguments like this so we put the first
premise of p1 p2 and the conclusion is c
at the end so just in case you need to
know
p1 any belief that teaches false views
about the natural world and ethics
should be opposed anybody agree with
that
yeah okay next
theistic religions teach false views
about the natural world and ethics
okay
number three our conclusions are
therefore theistic religion should be
opposed that's the argument
now this is a syllogism
and a syllogism is just a very concise
format for which the argument goes now
in actuality there is much more to this
than meets the eye
okay for instance in premise two
all right everyone agrees with premise
one but not everyone agrees with premise
two
now the new atheists will make arguments
for premise two okay so there's more
information that goes under there
all right so they'll say well we have
historical evidence that shows that
religions cause more wars or we have a
lot of evidence to show that uh there's
more extremists in religious societies
than non-religious societies so they'll
do this to back that up okay but you can
oppose this and say no that's wrong okay
but the actual argument itself is valid
and i'm going to teach you this also for
those of you who don't know uh any basic
logic
or have taken a basic logic course but
there's a difference between a valid
argument and a sound argument
okay a valid argument
means that it's logically consistent
that means that it it's coherent
okay
it's true by definition
all right however a sound argument is
true in reality
so an argument can be valid but it
doesn't mean it's sound it can be false
okay and if an argument is invalid then
it's automatically false
all right
so
this argument implies that such beliefs
are harmful to mankind an empirical
experience claim based on observation
okay and based on the belief of
anti-theism
next please
primary atheist arguments number two
the argument for the irrationality of
theism and religion theism being the
belief in god
p1 any claim that lacks evidence is
unjustified anybody agree with this
i'm going to try to change your mind by
the end of this course
okay
p2 unjustified claims are irrational
now is it everybody agree with that one
subjective it's subjective okay we'll
get into that
theism and religion lack evidence
okay therefore theism and religion are
irrational
implies that evidence is necessary for
every claim
the implication is there
based on the belief of evidentialism are
you starting to see connections
okay
next
the argument for the universality of
science
p1 evidence is necessary for any belief
to be justified and explained so this is
based on evidentialism the first premise
premise two science offers the only
reliable form of evidence and
explanation
theism and religion are beliefs
therefore only scientific evidence can
justify theism and religion
implies that evidence is necessary to
justify any belief basically from the
last argument
implies science is universal in
determining justification explanation
for any belief and based on the belief
of what
scientism
right next
the argument for evil and human
independence believe it or not
the argument for evil that we discussed
earlier
ties in
to what we're going to see is humanism
in a minute so we're gonna see it
through this argument
it is claimed that god is all-powerful
and all good is this correct in islam
christianity and judaism right
if god were all-powerful he could
prevent evil from happening
if god were all good he would not allow
evil to exist
a moral person cannot rely on or follow
a god that cannot prevent evil or does
not want to
evil exist
therefore god is either not all-powerful
or all good and thus mankind should be
what
apotheistic remember apathyism
means they should not care that he
exists or not
implies that the existence of evil
cancels out god's attributes and his
authority
implies that evil exists and there is no
good purpose for it at all
based on the belief of
humanism
and concludes that people should simply
not care about god's existence
okay
next
number five
the argument for incompatibility between
science and religion or you can just
call this the argument from the argument
for incompatibility
for something to be compatible it must
be complementary
okay so
that's very basic basically what i'm
trying to say there is that they should
not contradict each other they should
not
okay to reject one thing over another
means that something is not
complementary
society had to reject religious dogma
for science to advance
therefore religion is incompatible with
science now before we go into this
section p3 is the contested issue
p3 is the contested issue
okay the first two premises most people
will agree to the third one is the issue
did people really have to reject
scientific dogma i mean excuse me uh
that's also true but did they do they
really have to reject religious dogma to
let science advance that's actually a
common myth we read in that little nice
little fairy tale
that's what most atheists believe is
that the reason that we have scientific
advancement today the reason we have all
the health care that we have all the
weapons and technology that we have is
because
people
unburden themselves from the shackles of
religious dogma
okay because we are a
with the secularist
in the early time that's was claimed and
during the enlightenment yes in the
renaissance and things like this well
actually it started during the
renaissance fully enveloped itself in
the enlightenment period and then when
the state took over
they are claiming that um and they do
use the the history of the church
as evidence of this
however even that is contestable
because in actuality and i'm going to
just explain this more but since you
brought it up in actuality the catholic
church was a very big facilitator of
science
one of the largest
um in fact it gave more funding to
scientific to scientific inquiry and
technological production than most other
institutions did at the time now the
reason that we have some problems and
since we're already getting into the
topic i'll just sort of side track here
anybody heard of galileo
okay you know what happened to him
[Music]
they say is because he wanted to replace
a scientific theory
that the church upheld
now the church upheld at the time the
ultimate system which means that this
the earth was the center of the the
center of the universe okay and that the
sun rotated around the earth and the
moon okay so anyways
um
galileo apparently came by and said no
you're wrong it's copernicus theory
excuse me copernicus theory that was
correct and that everything rotates
around the sun
so because of this the church got scared
and said no you're wrong we're gonna
kill you because you made blasphemy
that's the simple story
the actual story is much more complex
than that in fact many of the early
church leaders were already
moving in that direction
the problem was is that when galileo was
trying to convince the pope you know the
pope at the time that his theory was
correct he was extremely insulting in
his letters
he used to call the pope stupid and
ignorant for not accepting his ideas so
the pope got a little personal and
decided to send his guards down there
and take him away so that was actually
the main reason it had nothing to do
with the fact that galileo just randomly
said one day oh
your theory is wrong and then they
killed him
that
that's actually very absurd and very
juvenile belief but in fact
a lot of atheists actually hold that
position they think that
scientists were just randomly persecuted
because they had different ideas
which is actually
usually it's more political than that so
okay sorry go back one more time so
okay so implies society rejected
religious dogma in favor of scientific
advancement implies religion was an
obstacle to scientific advancement we'll
discuss that more as well
based on supposed historical conflicts
between science and religion something i
already discussed just now in brief
based on the beliefs of what
progressionism
and scientism okay so one more
the argument for secularism now this is
a very important argument
and
it's probably
one of the most important ones that
you're going to need to learn as well
and this one is directly affects you
okay and this is something that our
atheists argue actually predominantly
in society
anything that predominantly causes
violence sectarism should never be a
governing force is this correct
anybody agree with this
anything that causes sectarianism and
violence should never be a governing
board meaning it shouldn't be in your
politics right you should not be
policing you it should not be governing
you okay
p2 religion predominantly causes
violence and sectarianism therefore
religion should never be a governing
force
that's the basic argument okay
and this is the main thing that atheists
will talk about
on and on and on and on and on and on in
their discussions even before the
existence of god comes into the picture
this is their main issue
is that religion
is a drive for violence and division in
society
okay
now
uh historical and observational claims
the supposed predominance of violence
sectarians and religion implies
secularism is predominantly peaceful and
unifying
and based on the beliefs of humanism and
progressionism before you go on
i will be discussing this at length this
discussion that's this this particular
argument because this is very important
for us so i'm going to give you a brief
of what i actually believe in this on
this position here
the historical observational claim of
the supposed predominance of violence
and sectarianism religion is false
obviously i'm going to say that you
probably already knew right
but it's
very false um the greatest atheist
argument i put a question mark there
because i want to save that for later
actually in part two
and
this argument
is important
for many reasons one
most atheists don't know that they're
making it
i know that sounds strange
they they subconsciously they make the
argument like this they have certain
beliefs that they form that they've had
from the previous beliefs that i
mentioned
and they make a statement
which i will mention this argument later
on
and
um it's very effective because they shut
down all conversation this way this is
how they win the argument against people
who have religious belief and
the other reason it's very important is
because it is the central argument that
i'm going to be using
in my own arguments
to refute them
so i'm actually going to be utilizing
this very
argument that they use which i'll
display to you in part two
okay to refute them so i'm going to use
their own argument against them
and i've been working on this argument
for
three years
yeah i know it sounds like ridiculous
like why would it take so long right so
because believe it or not
when you have
when you're around a lot of other
philosophers you're constantly being
critiqued so you have to keep like
redoing it
oh okay okay this could be problematic
so i'll change this word okay no i
understand where you're coming from
there i don't want to mess up so maybe
i'll
so you know you have to keep
reformatting until you get it just right
where it becomes uh annoying to people
and uh a philosopher knows that they
have a good argument when it annoys
people
you know so that's i know it's it's
quite funny but um
so
right as a as of
the third year i haven't had one
objection to it
so i'm quite happy
um i've showed it to other professors
they say it's valid sound so
i'm waiting for somebody actually to
give me something substantial so that's
why i like teaching it to people now
because i'm waiting for somebody to tell
me that's wrong because i want to see if
i can make it better you know
but um
so far nothing
it's like a perfect sudoku puzzle
um
so i hope that uh when i share it with
you
it's not patent by the way
so you can use it you don't have to pay
me anything
but
when you use it
insha'allah it'll be as effective for
you as it was for me
um i have counted the number of times
i've used it
and in every conversation that i've used
it it's been probably almost 200 now
i have
stopped the debate
um
and i've had a few people
not convert to islam but they became
fused
as a result
so alhamdulillah
it's hard it's much easier to actually
to get people to become theist than
muslims
you know
i know
so
[Music]
okay i believe this is the end of uh
part one
okay
so thank you very much uh we're gonna
have a quick break for about 30 minutes
maybe if we could extend a little longer
because i think people want to eat
breakfast
and uh well i'll determine that with you
later and we'll get into section two
section two before we go to the break is
going to be about basically the history
of contemporary atheism i'm going to go
through some of the leading figures what
they believe
and the progression of the beliefs from
a certain point in time
i'm going to discuss why there's
actually a rise in atheism i'm going to
give you the exact reasons
and i'm also going to discuss more about
scientism and i'm going to discuss this
argument as well at the end
so
please enjoy your break
and um thank you for listening me
blabber on
thank you